[Musique]
mais
derrière le costume un artiste yvelinois
tony bastions pendant trois ans il a été
le baryton de la franchise française des
voca people
les chanteurs a cappella une audition je
suis pas du tout en habitué des
auditions au contraire mais j'ai vu ce
spectacle un jour à bobino et et quand
je les ai vus j'ai dit faut absolument
que nous aurons dans cette troupe et
l'audition est arrivé en france et je
les passais et j'ai passé toutes les
étapes et je suis rentré ça a été
magique
[Musique]
mais son premier amour artistique c'est
la trompette tony battie ans comment son
parcours culturel comme musicien qui
prend sa source dans son enfance
mon papa était trompettiste j'ai vu donc
copier mon héros mon père donc voilà
j'ai voulu faire de la trompette comme
lui et puis j'ai fait des études aux
conservatoires de versailles et le chant
était lié avec la trompette donc je me
suis aperçu que la compet on était un
petit peu derrière et moi j'avais envie
d'être un petit peu plus de vent sur
scène donc j'ai pris le champ voilà un
devant sur scène qui le pousse un projet
fou en janvier 2011 il lance un cabaret
à cerner la ville sur le modèle des
références parisienne le cabaret du bout
des prêts un projet réalisé avec son
entourage notamment son épouse
rencontrée sur les bancs du lycée à tony
le chant la présentation et la partie
administrative
amandine elle dansait s'occupe des
costumes un passionné comme il dit voilà
s'il n'y a pas de spectacle
il lui manque un truc il se sent pas
bien c'est vraiment quelque chose qui en
complément enfin qui fait partie de sa
vie c'est ça fait partie de ces enfants
aussi si le cabaret et les spectacles en
général un monde de glamour et de
paillettes qu'ils ouvrent depuis deux
ans un petit garçon
[Applaudissements]
dix ans mais nous et marquent quand même
que les artistes y en a de plus en plus
donc j'espère que vous n'avez rien
jusqu'à 10 heures la soirée inattendue
vient en aide un attend 10 ans atteint
d'une maladie neurologique orpheline
c'est un artiste talentueux avec un
énorme coeur est très généreux et ben
voilà il a tout fait don qui propose
savoir il propose son cabaret ses
danseuses aussi son réseau d'artistes un
nouveau projet lancé avec huit chanteurs
tony bastion fonde les nouveaux
compagnons un album sort au printemps
[Musique]